across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves and survival is the goal it's
into the spider hole go fast fast fast
fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
so i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of four
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans if there's an emp attack
this shipping container will be perfect
gone to great lengths i keep a box of
crushed glass by the door for security
and made huge personal sacrifices to
ensure their very survival i like this
skin because it splatters like a shotgun
best thing to do is don't break in my
house the experts will assess their
extreme preps and decide if they have
what it takes to face armageddon
doomsday run out of bullets this is the
product you really want to see and to
survive tim look at me this is doomsday
preppers
[Music]
tim ralston lives a normal suburban life
outside of phoenix arizona
with his wife and three kids but his
two-car garage doesn't house the
family's suv instead
it is a staging area for the apocalypse
let's go boys
it's it's a passion work together come
on good job good job we've probably
spent anywhere from 20 to 30 000 on all
the prepping supplies that we have we
got to get this stuff load up
anybody that doesn't take their own
self-preservation to heart is doomed for
failure i refuse to be a victim
[Music]
my major concern is an electromagnetic
pulse or emp
an emp attack can happen
without us even knowing you're feeling
it
an emp is a surge of electrical energy
that has the power to wipe out every
electrical appliance in its path
if a nuclear bomb was detonated high in
the atmosphere over the central united
states it would likely cause a
nationwide emp
russia china north korea they all have
the technology for an emp
our society is based on electricity and
if an emp goes off we have no more
electricity you're just going to turn
stuff on and it's not gonna work
basically we're gonna be put back into
the stone age
kids go help your mom and tim is not
leaving his family's survival to chance
in the beginning my wife really wasn't
on the same page as as i was pass around
i've actually been a closet prepper for
quite some time it's been one of those
take grocery money keep a couple dollars
back she's like why is the bill so high
but in reality the more information i
started to give to her then it opened
her eyes to the other potential threats
that are out there
but what started as a secret hobby has
become tim's life obsession i do
consider myself a prepper entrepreneur
james have you seen this done before tim
and his business partners james and nick
have made a career from inventing
survival tools that they believe will
give them an edge in the apocalypse
when we invent the product we're
thinking honestly of ourselves and our
families and what we need to do if
there's going to be an emp attack
cool today one of their latest
inventions has arrived back from the
manufacturer
nice
gentlemen krovo meeting it's called the
crovol i came up with the idea for the
krovel when i was repacking all my bags
it's taking 13 different tools that
weigh about 45 pounds into one tool and
it only weighs 5 pounds here's our new
version that we gotta test out today so
it's a different paint it's much tougher
um and we also have the new z spike
which is crazy feel that that lethal
it's like a it's like a warhead
tim has designed the krovo to handle any
apocalyptic situation from shelter
building to home defense it's an axe a
machete a hammer a nail puller a chipper
it's a breaching tool it's a chair and
it can even open up your beer
thank you sir
feel good cheers cheers
but there is one function of the krovel
that tim james and nick have not yet
tried out they want to see if it can go
beyond a multifunction tool and become a
weapon after an emp when you run out of
bullets you're going to want to have
something that uh intimidates somebody
else um and could potentially uh take
down a foe so tonight they are testing
it on
a dead pig weird
ah that's weird
oh look the eyes are looking at me
pigs are physiologically very similar to
humans and pig's organs are used during
surgical learning exercises at u.s
hospitals
slicing a pig is really stimulating if
somebody were standing in front of you
okay he's on after an emp a law-abiding
citizen would actually rob you for your
food they would kill you and potentially
look at eating you as food step back i
don't want to hit anybody all right
it's really just showing the power of a
crowball and how you can utilize it as a
self-defense weapon
oh my gosh
yeah
taking care of business it can go
through just about anything i mean we're
talking bones that thick with one swipe
flesh bones
thick bones thick flesh oh man it's it's
much better than i thought it was gonna
be i think that pig speaks for itself
there's not much left of them this is
the tool that you're gonna need if
there's a end of world scenario
this one will save your life
like many other city folk tim and his
family are building a second home in the
country but not for summer vacations
instead they are constructing a secret
desert bunker that will be used as a bug
out location in the event of an emp the
reason we decided to build an
underground bunker is for safety of our
family and our team james and i have
been working
for about six months on the different
designs
this will be one of the living quarters
back here okay in this shelter here you
could actually stay for days weeks
months even years if you had to it's
pretty cool
today are going to look for shipping
container to start our underground
bunker
tim has chosen to build the shelter from
shipping containers usually built to
transport tons of commercial goods
across the ocean
hello hey how you doing tim ralston how
you doing michael nice to meet you nice
to meet you michael i'm looking to buy
some containers all right do you know
what size you're looking for i'm ideally
looking for a 40-footer and possibly
looking at some 20-footers too the
reason i chose a shipping container is
it's already got all the reinforced
walls we don't have much time so it's
kind of already pre-fabbed for us all
we're doing is building out the insides
shipping containers cost around twenty
five hundred dollars each and are a
cheap prepper alternative to custom-made
shelters which can cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars okay um this is
what they call a high cube which is
actually a foot taller yeah so it's nine
and a half if there's an emp attack
this shipping container will be perfect
because the metal frame around it
protects everything that's electronic on
the inside the electric surge caused by
an emp will pass around the metal walls
of the shipping container rather than
through them protecting any electronics
placed inside so what are you gonna be
storing it me my family
yeah we're going to be uh putting them
up north uh underground we're looking to
put three of them together carve out the
centers okay and then connecting them
all together kind of like uh little
underground condos really okay no we
don't have a lot of requests for for
burying containers to put your family in
so how many people are you going to be
storing in here well right now i have
we have about six team members my
question is is that you've got one of
these stacked on top how heavy is that
thing uh empty uh it's about ten
thousand pounds all right so if i'm
putting like six eight feet of dirt on
that this steel container can hold that
right it can but you're gonna need to do
some reinforcement yeah once you get in
these things they're so much bigger
because we have it laid out where like
in the front area i've got a small
little entertainment area and then i
could do literally a bunk here
another bunk here i love this one you
know i love the extra the height so i
think this is the one
i was overwhelmed by my shopping
experience oh man it was fantastic yeah
um is exactly what i wanted it was and
actually built stronger than i thought
they would be you know i just can't wait
to get this thing delivered we're gonna
make this thing look fantastic sounds
good thanks very much thank you
tim has carefully selected the perfect
location for his underground bunker
hidden in the desert hills outside of
phoenix
and every couple of weeks he and his
kids run a full practice bug out his
code phrase for disaster is we're going
on vacation all right boys let's go
we're going on vacation come on help me
out let's go work together come on good
job good job i feel a lot safer because
we're totally prepared and
we'll be ready for anything
good job trey the drills are first so if
anything bad does happen that we do it
like clockwork and it gets done fast
let's go rich oh nice our motto is to
travel fast and travel light as quickly
as we can and get away from a populated
area set it
let's go
okay rich guide me in trey get in the
truck the plan is to get his entire
family to the desert bunker in less than
40 minutes just ready start the timer
yep all right hit it
bridge you know timing is everything
when it comes to uh
this bug out evacuations
how are we doing on time we're about 20
minutes into it
all right ridge we are officially
here stop the clock what do we got we
got
34.49 fantastic we made our best that's
our best time
once there tim and his sons build up
their prepping skills by practicing
tactical shooting loads
we train as often as we can out in the
desert there's no restrictions like you
would have in a gun club so we're able
to do more real-life situation shooting
all right so what we're gonna do uh
balloons are gonna represent a good guy
and a bad guy all right the bad guy is
the red guy
nice shot go go go get him get him get
him
again
nice shot so it teaches them the fire
under pressure and the fire accurately
just out growing into the gun
that guy i'd have behind me any day my
dad um
is out there and he's kind of different
he
trains a lot and
is always telling us to be prepared
and
just hope for the best and prepare for
the worst i think every american
household should have done never have
enough guns never enough ammo
as a prepper tim knows that at any
moment the unexpected can happen
what happened
what happened damn thing uh
just misfired on it get the truck up and
running he's gotta get the last ball
yeah okay
tim tim look at me
look at me
jim
when i first saw the wound i i
truly thought he was gonna lose his
thumb
look
as soon as tim's gone misfired and hit
his thumb the film crew's emergency
medic jessie ellerbee took swift action
his thumb right between the two knuckles
had a wound to it it channeled out the
middle essentially it's still connected
or you believe it's still connected when
it happened instantly all i did was
thank god it wasn't my son
all right
get the truck up and ready he's gotta
get lost yeah okay my main concern was i
wanted to get him out of there as
quickly as we could thank god that the
emt was there we evac to a helicopter
went to the hospital they had me in
emergency surgery within like an hour of
me arriving it was one of those
malfunctions my thumb went in front of
the barrel and it went off here's some
of it huh is that pretty but i wouldn't
look at the hand
after i saw it happen i never looked at
it so now i basically left with a little
[ __ ] digit and uh it looks the same
it's just much much shorter with no
knuckle
so guys you know i just wanted to let
you know that i was really proud of how
you acted out there when the accident
happened and ridge you're 100 right you
never put
anything over the barrel that you're not
willing to lose i knew he was gonna be
okay because he's pretty tough
very tough until he passed out i did
pass out didn't i
i tried not to the shooting in the
desert will affect him physically for
the rest of his life
but he's no less passionate about
prepping if an emp does hit it's going
to get a lot worse than what this thumb
accident happened as a prepper the most
important tool is your mind you have a
survivor's mindset things like this you
can persevere you can push through when
it comes to my guns and and training
nothing has changed i actually be some
new guns that i'll be adding to it it's
still an essential part of our survival
plan i don't give up i don't quit you
just don't do that
the experts practical preppers conclude
that you have thought out your bug out
strategy in great detail your fitness
level special equipment and extensive
training will serve you well in a crisis
situation but important steps need to be
taken to construct your bug out location
as quickly as possible
yeah i agree i need to get it done as
fast as possible it is our top priority
in order to defend your family you will
also need to learn how to operate
weapons again with your disability when
it comes out of survival situations i
believe i'll be the guy that comes out
to lead but i need to learn a few more
things there's always room for
improvement
hi everybody it's been about two months
since the
last time we were filming so recovery
still going really slow but we've taken
everyone's suggestions to heart and uh
have really stepped up our game first
aid obviously we know we needed to
upgrade that just in case this is the
mack daddy of all first aid kits and the
shelter it's doing really well we're
working on it as we speak so i hope to
have that thing finished by this summer
other than that we hope for the best and
prepare for the worst
what are the odds of an emp attack
actually occurring while some prominent
political figures have spoken about the
possibility of an emp crippling us
infrastructure most experts agree that
such an attack is unlikely
jason charles is a husband father and
new york city firefighter his neighbors
know him as one of new york's bravest
but what they don't know is that he's a
prepper
i'm preparing for the yellowstone
national parks super volcano to explode
a normal day in the life for me is
basically uh work taking care of the
kids and prepping
i can't be obsessive about
prepping at times
before i met met my husband i never even
thought about preparing but we speak
every day about end of the world
situations when you're prepping you just
don't stop you keep going you prepare
for disasters like they're going to
happen
in fact they will happen
over the last 2.1 million years the
yellowstone super volcano has erupted
three times approximately every 700
thousand years six hundred and forty
thousand years ago the last eruption at
yellowstone blasted huge volumes of
volcanic material into the atmosphere
ash fell as far away as iowa and
louisiana and some like jason believe
the next explosion is looming
[Music]
when it goes off it'll create mass
destruction across the united states
probably within a week the ash will have
made its way around the planet killing
plant life killing animal life and
killing human life
no food no water would throw people into
a uh a panic
in new york city there are 27 000 people
per square mile
making it the most densely populated
city in america
and jason believes that more people
equal more danger
my main concern with prepping in a city
is security it's just the massive amount
of people that live in new york would
create a lot of pandemonium a lot of
problems once people find out a disaster
is going on they're going to start
looking for other means to gain food and
water therefore they start raiding a lot
of apartments potentially
killing you in the process
there are over 250 million privately
owned guns in the u.s and firearms are a
prepping staple
but not for jason
living in new york city handguns it's
incredibly hard to get these are my
knives some of them are menacing looking
it's another knife i would clip on my
belt this bully good self-defense weapon
if you know how to use it why do i have
so many knives well you can't have a gun
so this is as
good as it gets jason owns 10 bladed
weapons and is currently learning more
about knife fighting so that he can
protect his family
for an urban prepper space and security
are the two biggest things right now i'm
going to the roof to learn knife
fighting
amerifist jason has booked a private
lesson with former israeli army special
ops officer matan gavish who trains the
new york city police academy in krav
maga the official self-defense system of
the israeli armed forces
if we come to a point where we deal with
the end of the world you want to make
sure you're on the lion team in the
jungle and not running around with the
gazelles
straight into here and that would that
would puncture the heart he will die
slowly and painfully
but surely
all right knife goes around the throat
walking into your apartment building
somebody comes behind you so from here
you raise your hands please don't hurt
me two hands go on the wrist drop your
weight tuck your chin to the left take
your hand out hold that hand with both
hands and slam the knife into him
repeatedly
so how would i protect my family in a
small space uh small apartment limited
room well the one thing you want to
always remember keep your family out of
the violent engagement as a firefighter
jason knows that new york school
children need to practice fire drills at
least 12 times a year but today his kids
are going to practice a different kind
of drill
see when an intruder walks into the
house
first thing you want to do is get the
kids away from that room guys you're
going to have to transform yourself into
human shield between the intruder and
your kid
it's good that he does practice when
there is civil unrest we're gonna go
high and above to protect ourselves
just like anybody else would
professional knife fighting skills will
help jason to defend his loved ones but
no knife can fight the ash cloud he
believes will be on its way to new york
jason charles is a new york city
firefighter who believes that the
yellowstone supervolcano will violently
explode and result in widespread
destruction
when a volcano erupts the most dangerous
thing is breathing in the ash build up
in your lungs and stop you from
breathing
essentially killing you
volcanic ash is extremely abrasive it
can cause lung problems and even damage
machinery
jason believes that its consistency is
similar to the debris from the 911
attacks in which he was an emergency
responder during the 911 attacks i
rushed down there
[Music]
trade center came down that stuff got in
your mouth and your lungs and you were
pretty much incapacitated when it came
to breathing the dust cloud is the
closest thing you'll get to uh super
volcano ash cloud 911 attack support me
to be prepared for any disaster
if a devastating eruption rocked
yellowstone again scientists believe
thick ash deposits would extend mainly
eastward threatening life for about 500
miles in that direction
ash would reach new york within a couple
of days
jason thinks his apartment is the safest
place to sit out a volcanic eruption and
is determined to be ready to bug in as
soon as disaster strikes
i want to start doing drills we'll seal
the apartment up okay so do you want to
do a bugging in like 15 minutes yeah why
not bugging in staying in home and
waiting out whatever the catastrophe is
it is turning your home into a bunker in
the first hour of the caldera explosion
plastic sheet over the window towel
under the door and set up your security
all right let's go
for bugging situation i keep a box of
crushed glass by the door for security
go in the kitchen fill up pots and pans
with water and i'll fill up the water
bottle volcanic ash can cause water
supply systems to clog and become
contaminated jason is worried that an
eruption could restrict his access to
clean water
as far as water goes living in new york
city i don't have an underground well i
don't have a creek nearby
i have a river that's going to be
polluted but my only water source is
going to be me putting away as much as i
possibly can today jason will collect
over 100 gallons of water using a water
bomb an emergency device typically used
by preppers in hurricane regions
we are sealed in all right water bob is
filled checked pans are filled check and
we have security sure and in what's the
time another
15 minutes we've got to go to 14. that's
awesome yes it is yay the
biggest limitation while prepping in a
city is space apartments here in new
york city are small we have less places
to put our items right now my plan for
food is to continue building my food
storage keep buying mres mres are
pre-packaged meals used by the us
military they can be stored for up to
five years their shelf life and compact
size make them a prepping mainstay
five sloppy joes
with this and the other one under the
bed and three boxes of mres in the
closet we have about four months you
think the kids would eat any of this
stuff a lot of chocolate oh maybe
meatloaf
yeah that would eat that mres taste like
crap but eating mres is a walk in a park
compared to what other people would be
doing to uh survive people do weird
things when they're hungry might run
into cannibals at that point in jason's
apartment there's hardly room for his
coats let alone his preps so he rents a
storage unit four blocks from home
filled with a one-year back-up food
supply
my strategy for food retrieval would be
going to the storage unit with my
tactical vest
scalp bag
and a military duffel bag stocking it up
and bringing it back to my family
tonight jason will test his retrieval
skills for the first time so if the time
comes he knows he will be able to save
his family from starvation
[Music]
so the ash should be thick that's why
i'm wearing the air tank
i have 45 minutes of air for food
retrieval if the ash is too thick and i
only have 45 minutes to retrieve the
food if i don't make it back in time i'd
essentially die all right that's uh 45
minutes on the air ready yep set go
it's 15 minutes in where are you
copy that i'm at the halfway point
all right 10 minutes left
jason successfully completes his food
retrieval in less than 45 minutes
my advice for everybody who's unprepared
to start preparing for any disaster that
might happen you never know when you're
gonna need that food supply that water
supply and i'll do what i have to do to
protect my family
jason the experts at practical preppers
determined that your newly acquired
knife fighting skills and bug-in
strategy could help protect your family
from the social unrest that would occur
if the super volcano explodes
however even with the preparations you
have staying in a small urban apartment
may not be sustainable we recommend
having multiple secure locations as a
backup plan
the wife and i
have already started looking at other
locations for uh security purposes also
it is in your best interest to include
others in your plan because you may not
be able to go about it alone
i also agree with that um
i am in the process
of meeting more preppers in new york
city
what are the odds of a super volcano
explosion actually occurring
the u.s geological service notes that
scientists aren't convinced it will ever
happen again
eruptions like this are regular and
unpredictable
but they give a rough estimate of the
yearly odds as around
0.00014 percent
jules durves believes that an impending
food crisis will cause mass starvation
his answer is to create an urban garden
of eden on just a tenth of an acre
but will it be enough
[Music]
jules durvez lives the sun-kissed
californian life he loves to garden and
shares his home with his three grown
children but
he is also a prepper
we're prepping for a catastrophic
collapse of the modern food system
oh man
in years to come i didn't want my family
to turn around and say dad why didn't
you do something i had to take action so
we prepare we don't wait for something
to get worse
a lot of farmers here in america are
going to genetically modified crops and
we feel that's a disaster waiting to
happen genetically modified or gm crops
are created by altering the dna of
natural seeds to increase crop yields
resist pests and reduce crop failure
more than 2 billion acres of gm crops
have been planted worldwide since 1996
the threat is they have super bugs
coming on that they're worried about
the past adapts
jules believes that pests supposedly
weakened by gm crops are instead
starting to adapt and fight back they
are actually becoming stronger as a corn
rootworm that worm is even stronger a
recent study from the iowa state
university shows that some corn
rootworms are developing resistance to
gm corn a crop that has been planted on
millions of acres in american farmland
if this corn crop were to fail the u.s
could lose hundreds of thousands of tons
of food
when you have a shortage you're going to
have riots people are just going to
demand food it's a gamble and i'm not
willing to take the gamble
ten years ago jules decided to opt out
of the weekly supermarket shop and grow
as much of his own food as possible
i call it having my own alamo here where
i said i wasn't going to take this any
longer i'm going to
grow my own food no matter what and to
be more prepared for the future the food
they grow now makes up to 90 of their
diet during summer months you know it's
a regular 360 day year job we're
gardening all the time
grow 188 pounds of beans 38 pounds of
carrots 241 pounds of cucumbers 109
pounds of onions 115 pounds of peas 500
pounds of salad mix 113 pounds of
peppers 958 pounds of tomatoes my son
justin grows so many tomato plants that
i ask him to stop
but this bountiful harvest isn't from
acres of rural pasture
it's from their suburban backyard right
next to a major highway
we have 11 lane interstate 100 feet from
our backyard
this is my yard in pasadena california
and it's not your typical yard it's a
jungle but it's a good jungle because
it's full of food
to make the most of their small lot the
duvets follow a simple urban rule if you
don't have enough space to expand out
you can instead
build up there's food up there not just
on the field on the ground but there's
food on the fence line
there's food above you there's food on
the side of me there's food everywhere
each night they sit to eat the fruits of
their labors this is what we're gonna be
eating for the next couple months here
some
larger than others this is 25 pounds of
squash that's survival like this is
their survival weapon there's more
oh man this is a bug
we've been blessed to have um abundance
breakfast squash lunch squash dinner
squash
the durvase daily grocery bills are
equivalent to buying a couple of lattes
on the way to work
we can get by on two dollars a person
per day to feed the family afford here
[Music]
jules is determined to be independent
from more than just the local
supermarket
he fears that a food crisis will cause
widespread hyperinflation making basics
like gas and electricity luxury items
and his best insurance policy against
living without
is to live without my prepping is less
resources less electricity less fuel
the average american family spends over
three thousand dollars a year on gas but
not jewels
if he wants to fuel up he doesn't go to
the gas station
he just heads to the local fast food
joint
well they bridge here to a caterer we uh
bring up edible flowers and some
fruit and
other vegetables too and they
uh fry their food there so we get the
waste vegetable oil we got your order
here sweet how much you got uh it's two
that's good yeah but they're nice and
dirty they're gonna use it for something
gets out of our hair doesn't cost me
anything so i'm all for that back at the
house the dirty fried oil begins its
transformation into a fuel that can run
the family's aging mercedes for less
than a dollar a day
okay this is our
uh biodiesel processor what we do is we
pump in the vegetable oil into this
electric water heater heat it up to 130
degrees and add methanol and lye to
separate glycerin out of the vegetable
oil we pump it into a 55 gallon drum and
we wash it it takes us about 30 hours
from start to finish so we turn this
waste vegetable oil here
into the clean biodiesel if we were to
buy our supply of fuel it cost us about
five dollars a gallon but to make it
that cost us about a dollar a gallon by
using biodiesel the duvets save up to
eighty percent on regular gas prices
over one thousand dollars a year by
diesel is so safe you can even drink it
the durva's backyard is also home to
eight ducks two goats a cat and a host
of chickens my daughter jordan she's
taken to the animals and she's really
modern-day heidi she has a way with
animals animals i don't know if she
actually talks to him but they seem to
respond to her she's raised a lot of
them from babies so she relates to them
and and vice versa this is anali
beulah opal that one's bella lula bell
stella dora this is blackberry this
one's eight years old they don't live
really beyond five but she's doing well
so i guess i'm doing something right
everybody else seems to be looking to be
dependent on government dependent on
corporations dependent on the banks
dependent on others but we are providing
for ourselves and living a
self-sustaining life here
the experts practical preppers
think that your impressive garden will
see you comfortably through a food
crisis
but we suggest that you improve your
long-term supplies
we agree we can do better on our food
storage and stockpiling we like to add
more additional canned goods and bulk
staples to our food security
you should also consider purchasing a
diesel generator so that in a blackout
you can use the biodiesel you make to
help power your home
we knew that having a backup plan like a
diesel generator is a good idea it was
just uh right now the cost would be too
much for us
this fall we increased our stockpile of
home canned goods by putting up almost
800 jars of fruits and vegetables
preserved from our summer harvest
also we purchased an additional few
months supply of food staples from our
co-op
and stored over 150 gallons of water
as for our energy needs we purchased
additional firewood for heating and for
outdoor cooking and it got an extra
supply of rechargeable batteries
what are the odds of a nationwide crop
failure actually occurring
although certain insects can form
resistance to genetically modified crops
farmers use a variety of methods
including planting techniques and
insecticides to combat this
pat vrabel believes we are on the brink
of an economic catastrophe there's a
fear of the new president coming in and
taking a lot of our rights away he has
spent thousands of dollars on food
stocks and even more on firearms
but how prepared is he
and what will the experts think
yeah i didn't think it would be that
long pat brabel lives in a small town
and runs a family business
he's a church-going southern gentleman
lord god you have made a way for many
people to be blessed who loves his wife
lynette
and north carolina's country living
he also loves prepping
i'm preparing for the downfall of
society through hyperinflation
i've been prepping that for about two
years
my life is different since i've started
prepping
it's always in the back of your mind we
just started buying a few items here and
an extra few items there and the last
two years i've been on it pretty
aggressively probably
would spend
seven eight hundred dollars a month
easily and i'm always thinking now
what do i need to put up
in this country
prices are definitely going up that's
inflation
if it continues to get worse and the
salaries don't rise with it then it will
be a collapse
people was going to panic
when the economic collapse does happen
you couldn't get any money out of the
banks
people couldn't get gas at the local gas
station and if they can't pump fuel they
can't get groceries into town people
will do whatever they have to do to feed
their family
i think it would be pretty bad pretty
quick i believe it's very possible that
this could happen very soon
and in the two years that we have been
prepping out have spent approximately
ten thousand dollars
on food and supplies we are preparing
for us our friends our family
honey can you go to the barn and get me
a jar of peanut butter
pat follows the prepper's rule of
operational security he keeps his preps
in a secret location on his property
only family members and close friends
know its whereabouts
the 20 by 20 room holds their entire
stockpile including 200 gallons of water
30 jars of peanut butter and 200 pounds
of sugar
between 4 and 500 pounds of sugar that's
my ultimate goal you get a little bit
more sugar you reckon yes all right we
do need sugar make some candy this
happening
wow seventeen dollars going up big time
in the last couple months patton how
y'all i'm doing good how you doing all
right
what's the deal with aluminum foil going
up all metal products are going up is
that right yeah looks like he got a
whole lot of sugar here we might make
some candy some peanut butter fudge did
you see on tv about the peanut butter oh
yeah peanut butter 40 by january that's
crazy
when the crab hits the fan
i think people that have prepared are
going to survive 230 106. 230 106. right
pat and lynette spent 400 every month on
food for their supply room and today
they will spend nearly as much on an
additional prepping staple
i think alcohol is a good commodity to
have because it can be used for trading
bartering
there was a total economic collapse here
in the united states it does not have a
shelf life many preppers plan to use
alcohol as a post-apocalyptic bartering
item because of its multi-purpose
qualities
it can be used to disinfect wounds and
is an alternative to fuel
and of course there's also its age-old
customary use some folks may even want
to get it to have a big party there'll
be a lot of folks that don't care just
let's have a big party and let's just
end it all got 10 bottles there for
222.03
you guys going to drink all this we
actually don't drink we're going to use
this for for borrowing and trading okay
all right
we have all this booze and me and my
wife do not drink a lot of folks thinks
that is funny but regardless if i drink
or not
it is part of prepping
[Music]
patin lynette's alcohol supply isn't
just a post-economic collapse substitute
for money
we can also use it for making a small
bomb if need be
montauk cocktail is great if you need to
deter some people from coming to your
supplies it will definitely back some
people up
tonight pat and his brother will test
what could be their first line of
defense if disaster strikes
is my life insurance paid up
[Laughter]
anything above 120 proof will make a
great weapon
seem to work on tv so
it works in real life too wow that is
very effective
we need some marshmallows and some hot
dogs
why are you always wasting my
alcohol getting costly
worst case scenario that would be a very
effective weapon there it is don't miss
getting on right now
but pat has more than one way to defend
his stockpile in fact he has over 60.
pat brabel is prepping for extreme
hyperinflation which he believes will
result in a breakdown of society but
what would happen if his home and all of
his preparations came under assault
there is
60 or 70
weapons that are in my safes
as an american i believe 100 in the
constitution you should be able to
protect your family with your handguns
your shotguns your rifles or whatever
you may have
this first gun is an ar-15 223 camp 45
the whole barrel is a silence bolt
action rifle 30 all six that's just a
little 22 rifle it's a little old 38 i
use it for shooting snakes i don't like
snakes smith and wesson aerolite fhn57
flare gun that'll be in my bug out bag
if i ever need it
this safe is shotguns and rifles 30 all
six is seven millimeters 12 gauge slugs
it's a nine millimeter with an ankle
holster
it's made of sheepskin so it's very
comfortable just put it on strap it on
uh nobody never know you have it wear it
to the mall you can wear it up town you
can wear it to walmart
i keep at least one gun in my truck i
usually carry at least one gun on me 380
that he usually keeps in his back pocket
and this is a 22. nice and hidden one
right over here it's actually going
mounted to the side of my recliner
there's a gun in my closet shotgun we
keep this in the nightstand by our bed
my wife has a gun in her pocketbook my
wife keeps a gun in her car and there's
probably other guns hanging here too
me and my wife we are both born again
christians i believe there is a life
after this life
but in this life we need to prepare
religion will be important in tough
times you know always keep your faith
thank you pat lynette for what you've
done with this this uh this room would
really like to just say a blessing over
what you've done here and give god
thanks for all the provision that he has
made for you
lord you have made a way for many people
to be blessed we come to you tonight
just thankful
humbled lord god at your provisions and
we thank you for that god should hard
times come we know that
we have a place we can run to i always
keep your faith
and the bible talks about
your house
and
things that you'll go through
and
economic collapse could definitely be
one of those trials that we have to try
pat lynette the experts practical
preppers determine you've established an
abundance of materials for trade which
would be useful in the event of an
economic collapse
also you have enough provisions to
sustain your family for several months
in a disaster
however your water supply is limited 200
gallons of water is not a long-term
solution you need to find an alternative
water source such as a pond or stream
and a way to purify the water you
collect we work on the water supply
probably monthly what we have actually
have physically on hand we buy bottled
water we buy water by the five gallon
jugs additionally your stockpile will
only last for a limited period of time
you need an alternative plan such as
gardening
we haven't really been very much on
gardening i grew up on a farm raising
chickens and stuff like that we could
definitely do that
since y'all were here i have been buying
more water since the
farming part i have talked to a friend
of mine and
me and him are in process of working
together on that i'm still working on my
ammo i have plenty of guns if i get
opportunity to buy a gun and wheel we've
had a ball prepping and we'll continue
to do it for years to come
what are the odds of catastrophic
hyperinflation occurring while the fed
considers sustained rises and commodity
prices a threat in the coming years they
project only modest inflation rates of
about 2 percent over the next several
years
[Music]
you